we should address the latest  developments in the step stones my lords  where i wonder is our prince damon was a  decade ago and he has since left the  region undefended we have left it  undefended  my queen  what are children  but a weakness  [Applause]  through them you imagine you persist  forever  you  will be hawking  we are the blood of old valeria  but for them you surrender what you  should not  the father compromised by the acts of  the son  [Music]  to have one child like that is a mistake  f3 is an insult  people have eyes  the consequences of an allegation like  the one you turned  would be dire  for free you can now listen to the  entire audiobook fire and blood on which  house of the dragon is based and which  covers the entire targaryen history  including current and future events of  house of the dragon for free with a  notable trial using our link in the  description